the forth more I want to consider is the
move Knight takes e4 afterwards black
should certainly capture this bishop not
only black gained the bishop pair but
right now black is stopping y2 castle on
the Kings side if this white knight is
going to the g3 then the d4 pawn drops
so that's why the most logical reply
over here for the white is to play
Knight to c3 and harassing the Queen and
here black should play the move Queen to
a6 so continue to stop white castling on
the Kings side and at this point you can
see if you look at carefully Black has
offered a pawn to the white and this is
what happened in most of the scenario
most of my opponent greedily capture
this pawn they think that okay we have a
chance of [ __ ] king and queen but
this line is very very good for the
black now before we look at that line
there's a one more try done by the white
which is why try to save this loose pawn
on d4 and in one of my game my opponent
played the move Bishop to e3 but such a
passive move will only help black to
gain the control so after Bishop to e3
black should capture this night and
after white recapture a black should
castle on the Queen side and not only
black has continuously stopping why to
cancel on the Kings side but black has
this wonderful bishop pair and in some
lines this d4 advance occurs and
that can create havoc in the white can
so this line is pretty good for the
black
so that's why the most logical reply
over here is Knight takes d5 and here
again I recommend that black suit castle
on the Queen side and attack that night
now the only good line here for the
white is to play Knight to f7
attacking both the rook and give up the
night and here black should certainly
capture this Knight which allows right
to capture the rope but now black can
play the move Knight takes d4 and now
you can see the first rat is looming
which is Knight take c2
so white is forced to play look to see
one afterwards black will give this
wonderful check which is Queen to b6 now
the only reply left here is King to f1
because if white plays Bishop to e3 that
will lose the queen
immediately after Knight takes e King to
have fun is pretty much force and after
King to have fun black will again give
the check by the Queen so Queen to a6
check
and if you look at carefully I have
highlighted by the arrows that if the
King goes to the Jeevan then Knight to
e2 check with at least gain a rook and
if King goes back again to the even
square then black can gain the vital a
two-pole and this turn out very well for
plat so that's why in the game my
opponent decided to play the move c4 so
blocking the check and now black plays
the move Bishop to d3 check
well after Bishop to d3 check King to e1
is very risky so the only logical reply
here is King goes to the G 1 square and
here I can play Knight to e2 check but I
find out that if white wants white can
sacrifice the Queen for the two pieces
because right now black rook is also
hanging so instead of that I found a
very strong move and probably that's a
winning move of the game and that is
rook to f5 stopping night two coming out
and now again threatening to play the
move Knight to e2 and after all this my
opponent come out with the move s3
now before s3 if I try to save the rook
let's say by a rook to e1 then white we
lose the Queen because after Knight
check King to have fun and Knight to c3
that Queen is a goner so that's why
white cannot afford to save the rope so
my opponent tried to give a flight
square to the king by playing the move
h3 but now the task has become very easy
so I played Knight check and after King
- H - I played Queen to d6 check and
here the force reply is therefore
afterwards black will capture that ball
with
and amazingly the pressure was so much
that my opponent played the MU g3 which
allow me to finish you instantly with
the MU rumor to have to
instead of the g3 if he would have
played the MU look to Jeevan then again
it's a mating fire it's an exercise for
you so try to find a mate in file so I'm
showing you right now
so the first move black should play is
hook to f2 so giving a check and the
only move left is king to h1 afterwards
that will give this night check and
after King to h2 a night to f1 check
it's a double discover check and after
King goes back to h1 we have a lovely
queen to edge to check
that game will give you a very good
illustration how to play against night
xe4 and night XD fine
the final move I want to consider is
Knight takes d5 and this is somehow the
most critical move in this line and to
my surprise not many of my opponent has
played this move but anyways you should
perfectly know what you are going to do
about it
because it's a very dangerous line so
here black has the only good reply which
is the castle on the Queen side and here
white has the three options so the first
option which I want to look out is
Knight to f7 again similar stuff which
we have seen previously and here black
should certainly capture this knight in
the view of white Bishop is falling
while it will go for the bishop takes c6
but here black has a wonderful shot
which is Queen takes d4 so why doesn't
have any time to capture the rook
because the mate is threatened on f2 so
white has to castle on the Kings side
afterwards black will capture this
bishop
now again here Toulouse has been tried
in the first game my opponent tried
Bishop III so he wants to save the
bishop but here black will be a couple
of piece up because I replied with the
move Queen to f6 not only attacking the
Queen but also attacking the knight and
in the game my opponent try to defend
the night with Queen to h5 but after
very simple g6 that Knight is a corner
and that means black is a two piece
ahead the more sensible reply over here
is Knight takes rook afterwards black is
going to capture this Bishop with the
knight so attacking the rook and after
rook to e1 now black has this wonderful
reply which is Bishop to g4 so hitting
the Queen and please note the f2 pawn is
pinned right now so the Queen has the
only place to go which is Queen to c1
afterwards
black will play this amazing move which
is Knight to f3 checker white response
is pretty much force White has to
capture this knight black will capture
the f3 pawn with the bishop and now mate
is threatened and no matter how hard I
try so in the game my opponent tried ash
tree but after Queen to h4 that pawn
will befall and
therefore the game will be over
so that is about Knight to f7
the second move is Bishop takes c6
afterwards black has to play this move
which is Knight takes dateable and the
amazing thing is white cannot capture
this night with the Queen because this
own rook is hanging and right now that
is also attacking the two pieces so my
response is pretty much force in one of
my game my opponent right bishop cross
p7 and after King takes he played the
move Knight to e3 so attacking my bishop
here I played a very cunning move which
is Queen takes d4 and after Knight takes
fi and queen takes e5 check my opponent
has to play Knight to e3 and if you call
the pieces right now although black king
is bit shaky but black is a clear piece
out and there are no immediate threats
for the black over here so this is a
winning position for black instead of
Bishop takes Bishop and check the wall
of s replies Knight to f7 once again but
here black can calmly take this bishop
the knight has been attacked and after
93 black can play this wonderful rule
which is rook to diesel
allowing Y to capture this bishop
afterwards a six will be happen black is
attacking the two nights so wear your
vests responses white will capture the
rook black is going to capture that
night and now you can see the downside
of the whole transaction that not only
white cannot capture this night with the
Queen but now black is threatening to
play Bishop to b4 and that can be rather
nasty so in the game I upon and try the
move f3 but this turns out that the game
will finish instantly so I played the
move rook to e7 check and after only
move King to f2 I capture that pawn and
after
King to g3 so King is coming up to the
borer which is always a good side and
here I replied with a move g5 and my
opponent decided to play the move ash
free so he's just giving some of the
escape square for the King but I want
you to pause the video over here and
find out the finishing blow
and the beautiful movies look to eat oh
it looks hilarious right because you
sacrifice in a rock but after Queen
takes rook Bishop to d6
is leading to checkmate in two
the last 10 the final move I want to
consider is Knight takes c6 which has a
cunning idea that is black foolishly
captured the bishop then Knight takes a
7 will folk the king and a queen but
here black has a wonderful reply B cross
C 6 so attacking the two-piece and if
white would have played Bishop takes c6
then our old friend Knight takes D 2
will give a great deal of problem to the
wine so not only white is a piece down
but black doesn't have any problems at
all so that's why Bishop to c6 it's
impossible so the only logical replies
Bishop to a6 check afterwards black has
to play the bow King to d7 and now that
night is hanging so the only logical
reply again is Knight to b3 attacking
the bishop but amazingly enough at this
point black can again play a wonderful
move Knight takes D to
so this theme crops again in again that
black can easily capture this bishop and
white cannot recapture it because Queen
takes room please remember that if the
King takes Knight then those lines are
very dangerous for the white in this
game my opponent right Knight takes
bishop but after a six attacking the
knight and knight drawbacks to the e3
black plays the move Bishop to b4
disaster is starting to looming on the
white camp so the discovere check is
threatened so the only logical reply
over here is King to e2 afterwards black
and simply snap of the d4 pawn it's just
a matter of taste whose position is
better so I give you a few more moves so
my opponent try the move Bishop to d3 so
blocking the diagonals and I played the
move King to e7 and it's time for the
assessment yes material is almost
balanced black has one pawn up but of
course it's a double pawn so you cannot
consider that much but the big idea is
look at the major pieces of the white
they all are sitting at the original
place and look at the tremendous
activity by black pieces so all in all
you can easily say this is a winning
position for the black so I hope you
enjoy this wonderful series of the
Colorado I have tried many many times
and I get a relatively good success so I
strongly recommend that you should
follow this amazing analysis and try in
your own game and you will be amazed by
how quickly you can win some of the kids
well thank you for watching this
wonderful series and it's time to go to
the next chapter which is the squash
game bye